[Background voices]
>> Hello, everybody at YouTube. I'm Helen
Fisher. I'm an anthropologist at Rutgers University
and I study the brain. And what I guess I'd
like the world to understand is that we've
got to educate little girls as well as little
boys because the female brain is very different.
It is-we evolved together-ah-millions of years
ago. I see men and women are like two feet,
they need each other to get ahead.
And the female brain is-is, on average, better
connected, giving them what I call webbed
thinking. They tend to think wholistically,
contextually synthetically. They think in
webs of factors, not straight lines.
And as I've studied people women tend to have
a better imagination because of this, they
tend to be more mentally flexible, they tend
to think long-term, they tend to be quite
nurturing and they tend to be able to live
with ambiguity. And I would say in our modern
world the most powerful--if I have to sum
up the modern world in-in one word, I would
say it is ambiguous. And if we begin to educate
little girls, we will not only educate them,
but we will educate their children and their
community and help to change the world.